comfortable now yeah yeah so I I just  wanted to check if they played if they  played earlier but they haven't so we  have basically a forest pairing on board  one tomorrow uh  we play against liernheim  yeah no but you didn't play because one  has 10 points and zeros or one has nine  so uh shock will be wide against Harry  on board one because even even the  colors work perfectly chocolate black  today and Harry played wide so we you we  even know that yeah  and then there will be a a massive  massive group of uh of teams on eight  points which will all need a win to have  a chance for for the pedestal finish of  course the main question for tomorrow is  is mazetovich  will be back I mean like I mean there's  a team I mean they need to win so they  need mazetovich obviously for the  tomorrow absolutely clear yeah  absolutely okay and though agreed uh